ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen minecraft
fällt meine lieben freunde und ihr seht
es bereits anhand meines mundes bzw
anhand meines zensierten bundes dass
mein mund zensiert ist es schön wärs ich
war vor einigen tagen in köln und wollte
dort einen kumpel beweisen dass ich auch
eine kölsch mit meinem hund auf ist mir
dann auch aufgefallen ich kann das nicht
weshalb ich dann auch am tag danach zum
arzt musste und er musste mir scherben
aus meiner lippe rausholen das ist jetzt
alles morgen zum glück endlich morgen
kommen die fäden auf jeden fall endlich
wieder raus die mir der arzt dort rein
gesetzt hatte denn meine rippen musste
natürlich heilen das musste alles
zugemacht werden und aber freue ich mich
auch schon extrem allerdings hatte ich
halt für heute noch kein video jetzt
wegen habe ich mir gedacht bevor ihr
jetzt irgendwie hier mal eine blutige
lippe lädt zensiere ich das einfach in
der aufnahme heute die ganze zeit ich
hoffe mal dass euch das nicht stören
sollte zu mir auf jeden fall weiter
allerdings sieht ihr auch schon dass ich
gerade mache denn ich habe mir hier
gerade einige birken im bäume um
rechts bietenholz hier verbraucht der
baum muss also ein großes loch was die
krippe hier angerichtet hat
dementsprechend werde ich denke ich auch
noch mal durch ich brauche hier vorne
einfach noch ein bisschen erde ab die
ich gleich benötige um eine insel da
vorne so ein bisschen zu reparieren wo
er am ende der letzten folge der keeper
in die luft geflogen ist da wollte ich
mich auch mal ganz kurz bei euch dafür
bedanken dass wirklich eine menge kommt
die nations hochgeladen wurden auf
youtube mit allen möglichen begegnungen
die ich in diesem projekt bisher mit
triton hatte also ich weiß nicht warum
ich hier so krass verfolgen bei
minecraft mit luca aber wir hatten
wirklich in jetzt mittlerweile 43 folgen
über ein
100 begegnungen ich guck mal wie schön
diese insel aussieht war die letzten
folgen in diesem projekt minecraft und
luca alle extrem lang waren habe ich mir
für das heutige video überlegt dass wir
uns komplett um unsere villa mal wieder
kümmern werden die seht ihr ja schon
dort hinten eingeblendet am horizont
[Musik]
sieht schon sexy auswendig schwimmen
zuvor möchte ich mir allerdings auf
jeden fall erstmal wieder ein neues
schild kräften bzw weiß ich gar nicht ob
wir eventuell sogar noch welche hier
drin haben ja haben mir sogar sechs
stück das heißt sie kann ich direkt mal
mitnehmen denn wir müssen uns auf jeden
fall auf unsere to-do-liste lka
schwarzes brett billboard ding hier
vorne ein schild dran setzen wo wir
drauf schreiben dass wir ja einen
hotspot haben und da dementsprechend
eine falle verbauen müssen das werden
wir auf jeden fall einer der nächsten
folgen machen das schwein muss er ganz
korrekt denn ich möchte hier jetzt erst
mal ganz kurz alles zu bauen
ich überlege gerade ob mit den weg hier
so runterziehen sollten genauso wie wir
ich habe ein bier habe ich versucht
aufzumachen
ja ich weiss ich finde den weg so schön
der hier untergeht und ich überlege
gerade ob wir den auch hier unterziehen
sollten die sache ist allerdings dass
die sonne gerade wieder runtergeht von
daher ich gehe kurzschlaf und bereite
alles dafür vor
so ich war ganz kurz mal wieder unten in
der höhle denn ich brauche auf jeden
fall noch ein bisschen cobblestone denn
ich überlege mir gerade dass wir den weg
glaube ich hier anfangen und dann immer
ein weiter runter gehen also ich frau
dass sie quasi ab dass hier auch den weg
hier machen wir auch mal weg weil den
weg zum lagerfeuer den brauchen wir
eigentlich auch nicht unbedingt
und dann geht es quasi hier runter hier
geht der weg weiter hier dann hier
weiter dann hier vorne da lerne ich
glaube ich auch noch mal ganz kurz das
eps 1
ich bin eigentlich relativ zufrieden
also den weg hier haben wir perfekt
runter ziehen können er geht hier zwar
einen zu weit allerdings habe ich dann
hier den sand ein bisschen aufgestockt
dann haben wir vorne endlich mal
vernünftigen weg hoch ich habe das ganze
lager vorher ein weiter herunter gesetzt
was er von perfekt was ich auch noch
gemacht habe war hier den weg so ein
bisschen ausgebessert weil das hier war
die ganze zeit grün und das war nicht so
schön aus und ich habe hier vorne einen
weg runter gemacht zu unserer portal
insel bin ich auch danke also das sieht
auf jeden fall ein bisschen schön aus
mit dem ja stimmt bevor ich mich
allerdings gleich und die komplette
moderne strandhaus villa kümmern werde
möchte ich erst mal ganz kurz hier vorne
einen neuen schuh errichten denn der
alte schwierig weiß nicht ob der immer
noch unten in der höhle schild oder wo
er sich gerade befindet aber wir
brauchen für diese in werther hat
gemeckert
wer hat gemeckert wo bist du ich höre
ich doch irgendwer hier mac hat mich an
[Musik]
die worte an ihn denn sonst natürlich
bei auszudehnen so aha der brauch
komplett platzte moderner ja ich habe
verstanden wir werden uns generell in
einer der nächsten folgen einmal
komplett um die villa insel hier vorne
kümmern da wird nämlich eine villiger
insel folge 2.0 kommen starten und die
ist doch schön ja alles geht immer
schöner guck dir mal meine lippe an also
wir beschäftigen uns allerdings um das
sollte jetzt endlich mal sagen erst mal
einen witz machen schornsteinfeger
urlaub in russland wir beschäftigen uns
jetzt allerdings für den rest der folge
mit unserer strandvilla dahin und ich
habe auch einige kommentare gesehen in
letzter zeit von wegen hey luca was
möchte dennoch so bauen auf einer insel
weil die mieter der kuhstall auch
abgerissen wird weil da hinten ja die
tiere insel hinkommt und ich nutze auch
dieses haus hier gar nicht mehr
also da können wir theoretisch auf was
anderes hin bauen die einzige sache die
wirklich für immer dort bleiben soll
hier vorne müssen wir dann im falle
hinten hin bauen
allerdings soll wirklich die einzige
sache seien diese immer auf meiner insel
hinten bleibt das grab hier vorne wo wir
auch noch mal ganz kurz
er schweige sekunde die verstorbene kuh
verstorbene katze verstorbenen pilze für
und die verstorbene schildkröte einlegen
können das grab ist wirklich das einzige
was auf dieser insel für immer bestand
haben soll und da hab ich mir sogar auch
schon gedanken gemacht um das grab so
ein bisschen schöner zu bauen das kann
ich euch mal hier oben rechts einblenden
was ich mir da gedacht habe die sache
ist allerdings dass ich wirklich erstmal
mich auf die sachen konzentrieren möchte
die wir gerade schon an themen aktuell
haben und dass es unter anderem diese
villa und bei dieser wille haben wir
einen kleinen fehler gebaut ist mir
aufgefallen
denn diese scheiben sind zu nach rechts
am eingang dran das heißt hier muss
glatter quartz blog runter diese scheibe
muss nach vorne gesetzt werden
da vorne packe ich dann auch direkt
wieder hier die glasscheiben reihen die
schwarz getönten sack und pack und die
hier vorne wird auch noch ein weiter
über gesetzt so dass das ganze dann
schlussendlich so aussieht das ist ein
bisschen neisser und was wir da hingehen
dann auch falsch gemacht haben ist das
hier vorne denn das hier soll nicht auf
diese höhe hier kommen sondern die
fenster sollen boden tief sein dass der
boden soll auf diese höhe hier kommen
also dieser trockene beton
dementsprechend kurze time letztlich den
ganzen boden eine höhere sätze
[Musik]
da wir den ganzen boden hier jetzt
abgebaut haben brauchen wir allerdings
auch selbstverständlich blöcke um das
als solcher schon voll wieder vergessen
die treppen platziere ich jetzt auch
einen höher ihr werdet gleich nachher
sehen am ende des videos warum wir das
alles hier machen die sache ist
allerdings dass er jetzt natürlich auch
erstmal blöcke brauchen die sonne geht
schon wieder runter es reicht natürlich
nicht jetzt einfach nur den ganzen boden
abzubauen und einen höher zu setzen
brauchen natürlich selbstverständlich
auch blöcke die sich dann wieder unter
dem trocken beton befinden von daher
packe ich erst mal alle möglichen sachen
hier rein so dass wir uns nun darauf
konzentrieren können hinten ich habe mir
dafür ein neues fass mit genannter
gesehen was ich da hingestellt haben
damit wir mal ein bisschen mehr platz
hier haben
ich habe mir gerade eine lore gemacht
und dass wir jetzt mal nach vorne fahren
können auf unser festland wo wir uns
dann neuen kies holen können und denen
dann dementsprechend als unterlage
benutzen können für unseren trocken
beton für die villa
eigentlich wollte ich mir fragen
raussuchen für diese fragen fahrt immer
auf die andere seite aber das habe ich
jetzt leider vergessen
so geht's bereits unten eingewendet ich
habe mir sechseinhalb stacks kies gerade
mal da vorne zusammengefahren das sollte
hundertprozentig reichen die sache ist
allerdings dass wir ja eh noch eine
menge beton brauchen wir brauchen wir
brauchen nicht nur eine menge kies für
das projekt was wir heute vorhaben also
den kompletten boden der strandhaus will
ja ein höher zu setzen sondern ließ auch
der essenzielle baustein beziehungsweise
gegenstand die wir benötigen um generell
noch weiteren beton zu machen den wir
auch für die villa benötigen die sehen
allerdings schon das die sonne dort
hinten auch schon wieder untergeht
dementsprechend fahren wir jetzt erstmal
an unserer strandhaus villa vorbei
hinten wieder in unser häuschen rein und
werden runde schlafengehen liga ich bin
so in love mit diesem schwert ist so
schön und ein wunderschöner neuer morgen
erwartet uns hier in unserer kleinen
süss micro fällt meine lieben freunde
ich werde dem schwein da vorne war so
süß gerade stand und zu mir herum
gelöscht hat jetzt mal ganz kurz eine
karotte geben der wurde in der letzten
folge 14 getroffen vom creeper deswegen
will z
kein problem wir konzentrieren uns nicht
auf das schwein denn ich hab's ja auch
im titel stehen und ich habe es auch
schon gesagt meine lieben freunde
ich möchte endlich mit dieser strandhaus
räder fertig werden und das ziel für
heute ist auf jeden fall erstmal die
küche es tut mir generell leid dass ich
in den komponenten video nicht so
richtig reden kann bisher haben viele
time lab zusammen staat ich bin sehr
steril sag ich mal von der materie das
richtige wort
ich weiß es nicht ich bin auf jeden fall
sehr zurückhaltend heute was das ganze
video angeht ich darf halt nicht nicht
richtig aufregen ich darf meinen mund
nicht weit aufreißen wegen den nähten
also ich musste auf jeden fall ein
bisschen vorsichtig sein ich hoffe und
bitte da einfach um euer verständnis
werde jetzt allerdings mal ganz kurz
hier alles voll waren mit kies und dann
mit trocken beton
[Musik]
so der komplette boden ist jetzt
ebenbürtig hier mit den fenstern und
dass sie deutlich geiler haus und dann
kommt hier vorne wirklich auf die höhe
in der wir das hier vorne auch schon
gesetzt hatten
auch dann die daher darauf dass auch die
kompletten fenster hier vorne werden
nachher alle so aussehen dass sie quasi
mehr oder weniger ja vorne von unten bis
oben gehen also bodentiefe fenster diaz
kann ich auch noch mal ganz kurz draußen
ich weiß ich wie hart angepackt hatte
hier hatte ich das und die anderen
sachen die habe ich jetzt hinten
gelassen allerdings kommt das dann hier
in das kommt nicht so hin
ihr merkt ich bin ein bisschen verwirrt
und es tut mir leid und im heutigen
video aber ich hoffe ihr könnt mir das
wirklich nachtragen nicht nachtragen
sondern geht schon wieder unterricht
muss schlafen es ist gegen eine ganz
komische folge heute und ich weiß dass
nur ich daran schuld werden und es tut
mir auch leid allerdings konnte wie
schön geworden
ich bin sage ich ganz geil dass hier
vorne sieht so ein bisschen komisch aus
mit der lehne hier vorne und die mit dem
lagerfeuer aber jetzt habe ich auf jeden
fall die vorne in vernünftigen weg
runter wir können brauche ich habe hier
so viele karotten da hingeschmissen wo
sind die denn
hol dir die x wir müssen uns noch ein
wenig vorbereiten und da würde ich euch
zum tausendsten mal heute time lab sein
werden es tut mir leid was machst du da
verständlich dass auch sehr schön ich
muss ich zum tausendsten mal heute
leider nicht am netz einblenden denn ich
muss mir noch mal ganz viele sachen
holen denn ich möchte jetzt die küche
bauen der pasta vorne auf
[Musik]
so da sind wir wieder in unserer villa
angekommen ich hab mir grad mal die
ganzen sachen gemacht die ich benötige
und als allererstes fangen wir mal hier
auf der seite an mit unserer kleinen
pflanze auf der ecke das sieht so auf
jedem fall deutlich besser aus das hier
vorne ein glatter quarz blockstreifen
ist und hier und dann hier der eingang
und die fenster die sache ist wie ich
möchte hier vorne die küche hin haben
dann machen nämlich 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
11 in die richtung und auch elf wieder
zurück jetzt fragt ihr euch luca was
soll den iren die ecke kommen dass hier
immer das falsch gebaut
ich habe mir irgendwie zu viel
vorgenommen für diese villa was die
größe angeht deswegen ziehe ich die
ganze außenwand hier von unserer villa
einfach mal zwei blöcke weiter ins haus
rein plus von außen sehen wir ja auch
noch hier den grauen trocken
betonbauweise den hellgrauen trocken
beton den minütigen die firma auch
deswegen werde ich den auch ganz kurz
durch tiefe setzten dem wir dürfen hier
wirklich keine blöcke verschwenden so
dass wir nicht noch zahlreiche folgen
den nutzen und uns quartz holen müssen
und so weiter und so fort
wie kann ich denn bei eineinhalb stunden
sein ich weiß dass das hier von außen
jetzt absolut herzlich aussehen wird
allerdings währte drumrum ja auch noch
hier von unten sieht auch ziemlich
bescheiden aus aber drumherum wird ja
auch noch ein dingens kommen also da
wird ja noch ein kleiner strand
rumkommen und so das wird man nachher
alles nicht mehr sehen
ich werde jetzt allerdings ganz kurz
noch mal eben schlafen gehen denn die
sonne geht tatsächlich schon wieder
unter es ist wirklich eine ganz ganz
komische folge ich weiß dass das jetzt
wahrscheinlich einige aufregung wird das
ich dass die ganze zeit sage und es tut
mir auch leid dass ich das die ganze
zeit sage allerdings tut mir leid dass
ich euch hier sonne folge heute mal
antun muss einerseits mit dieser
komischen blöde sache von meinem mund
ich will halt nicht dass das video
irgendwie nicht werbe freundlich wird
weil da noch im blut ist und treten und
keine ahnung was an der lippe oder
anderen seite ist das video allerdings
auch ein bisschen komisch weil ich keine
richtigen emotionen zeigen kann und was
ich auch nicht kann ist
richtig ich kann heute am stück nicht
richtig lange immer reden weil das sonst
weht an meinen lippen also ich deswegen
mache ich zwischendurch hat die ganze
zeit ein eps und muss mich so ein
bisschen darauf konzentrieren ab und zu
dann auch mal zu schneiden ich würde
allerdings sagen wir konzentrieren uns
jetzt erstmal auf die küche denn diese
beiden blöcke hier vorne werde ich
abbauen und darunter den tropfen beton
auch denn dort werde ich lag
und würde ich diese lagerfeuer hinsetzen
und auf eigentlich jetzt wahrscheinlich
hey warum denn der lagerfeuer keine
sorge freunde da drüber setzen wir jetzt
zwei räucherofen über die räucheröfen
setzen wir 2 eisen falltüren und über
die eisen falltüren vier stein
ziegelmauern das hier oben sind jetzt
nicht so schön aus dem manchmal ganz
kurz provisorisch ist ein bisschen
glatten quartz lock in damit sache so
aussieht
ich würde so gerne lachen aber es geht
leider nicht was wir nun als nächstes
machen ist hier auch sechs blöcke
abbauen und dementsprechend können wir
dar und hat dann auch dem trocken beton
abbauen ich weiß dass ich eigentlich ein
fan davon bin dass wenn ich hier und das
kann ich auch ab dass verbraucher bei
und bin eigentlich immer ein fan von und
das wissen ja auch dass alles überall
gleich aussehen sollte auch wenn man die
blöcke nicht sieht für mich fürs
gewissen hat dass darunter auch
trockener beton ist quasi die sache ist
allerdings dass wir davon wirklich noch
so viel benötigen und dann sparen wir
uns wirklich einiges an ressourcen denn
hier vorne kommen glatte quartz treppen
darauf die ort nicht so so und so an
dass sie soll nämlich das waschbecken
sein und dann können wir hier vorne auch
unseren teil grauen trocken beton wieder
hin packen jetzt benötigen wir
allerdings grauem beton allerdings nicht
trocken beton sondern normalen beton und
ihr seht schon das hier ist trocken
beton wenn er allerdings mit wasser in
berührung kommt die textur so ein
bisschen
ihr seht gerne und das benötigen wir
hier vorne als so ein bisschen
arbeitsplatte beziehungsweise
arbeitsplatte nicht unbedingt benötigen
das einfach hier vorne so ein bisschen
als wandverkleidung 3 4 5 6 7 und auf
der anderen seite zog auch noch mal
sieben da drüber setzen wir jetzt auch
unsere glatten quartz blog ich weiß ich
hab ich da ran komme ja das soll ich auf
jeden fall hinkriegen dass das hier wird
dann quasi das zweite stockwerk oben die
villa wird jetzt zwei stockwerke hoch
und ich finde das hat sie auch verdient
dafür dass hat die villa auch verdient
dafür dass wir dafür so lange im never
immer fahnen waren ich glaube in den
videos kam es gar nicht so krass darüber
welcher wert teilweise stunden im netz
verbracht und diesen ganzen quatsch
anstatt zu holen
jetzt werde ich hier vorne einen hebel
hinsetzen und den dann runter machen
dann sieht es ein bisschen aus dem
wasserhahn also mit viel fantasie und
jetzt nehmen wir unsere laterne die
kommt nämlich hier in die ecke da wollte
ich eigentlich bzw
im tutorial was ich euch auch und in der
beschreibung
verlinkt habe wo ich mir hier wieder die
inspiration holen da hat der so eine
nennt starb hin gepackt oder irgendwie
sowas das war auf jeden fall auch sehr
geil dass die bekommt man allerdings
erst wenn man am ende war in minecraft
und dort bonns glaube ich noch 200 jahre
und zu guter letzt packen wir nochmal
hier hier und beispielsweise hier vorne
einige stein knöpfe dran die so ein
bisschen so schubladen darstellen sollen
das tier wird dann tatsächlich unsere
küche auch sein und hier vorne kommt so
eine kleine bar hin die wollte ich heute
eigentlich nicht mehr bauen
und ich bin auch schon bei zwei stunden
allerdings ist es gerade 39 morgen so
ich nehme die folge wirklich richtig
früh auf weil ich dachte kommen wenn ich
schon hier so besitze mit einer dummen
mit meinem dummen mittel mit den dummen
fäden in meinem mund dann möchte ich mir
zumindest ganz viel mühe geben deswegen
hab ich mir gedacht kommen wenn es hier
um die strandvilla geht dann mache ich
das auf jeden fall auch noch heute und
werde mich dementsprechend jetzt noch
ein bisschen auf die baar konzentrieren
beziehungsweise erst mal ganz kurz jene
decke reinziehen
so die decke ist auf jeden fall drin und
wenn man sich hier vorne so hinstellt
dann denkt man auch wirklich schon dass
fast alles fertig ist klar hier ist noch
nichts eingerichtet ich habe auch
kommentare gelesen dass hier unten ein
gläserner teppich rhein soll so dass wir
quasi nach unten gucken können und dann
hier die ganzen korallenriffe sehen
können das möchte ich die nächste auf
jeden fall auch noch machen hier vorne
schwimmen noch ein bisschen beton von
mir rum und hier generell sieht alles
noch ein bisschen blöd aus der ferne
liegt auch noch beton die sache quasi
vorne die sache ist allerdings auch dass
wir fast kein platz mehr haben also wir
müssen definitiv normal farben gehen in
den neckar und ich muss mir auch
unbedingt jetzt noch mal ganz kurz die
sachen zusammen suchen die ich hier für
die bahn brauche
die sache ist allerdings dass ich hier
erst mal alles provisorisch ein bisschen
mit fackeln ausgeleuchtet dass wir nicht
gleich ein komplettes pieper paradies
wieder haben was ja typisch wäre für
dieses projekt hier vorne
deswegen würde ich euch ganz normaler
teil gab's einen blenden da die sonne
auch schon wieder relativ tief steht wie
ich jetzt schlafen gehe und mir die
restlichen sachen hole hier für die bahn
[Musik]
so ich bin endlich fertig das hat echt
ein bisschen länger gedauert die sache
ist das ist allerdings noch grauer
trocken beton fällt mir gerade auf das
heißt dementsprechend muss ich die noch
mal ganz kurz hinsetzen und dann wieder
abbauen davon brauchen wir 16 stück und
den grauen beton nehmen wir nun und
setzen die ihnen hier so hin 123456
jetzt hier runter zack zack zack zack
und zack die bohne wieder ab den habe
ich falsch gesetzt und die platten
steinstufen die ich mir gemacht habe die
packen wir jetzt hier oben drauf damit
das ganze so ein bisschen abgetrennt
aussieht hier noch eine hin und hier der
stein knopf kommt jetzt auf jeden fall
hier dran und dann habe ich nur noch
zwei haken gemacht wie setzen wir jetzt
hier und hier hinter soll so ein
bisschen zapfhähne sein wird
die glatten quartz blöcke nehmen wir nun
und platzieren die hier so lieber hier
immer so ein bisschen abstand zur theke
würde ich sagen und hier vorne auch noch
mal 1 2 1 2
und hier und jetzt nehmen wir unsere
klappen quads treppen und bauen hier so
eine kleine dings hin so eine kleine
sitzbank hier vorne die dann auch hier
vorne so rum um die ecke geht so dass
das ganze quasi schlussendlich so
aussieht und hier auf der seite auch
noch mal so abgegrenzt sein sollte dass
man sich hier quasi so dran setzen kann
das gleiche auch nochmal hier vorne
und hier können wir das ganze auch noch
machen und dann auch noch hier vorne an
der ecke zack und sagt ich könnte jetzt
ein theoretischer drunter den trockenen
auch noch wegnehmen aber das wird
was so machen oder das ich weiß nicht so
auf jeden fall nicht ganz schön jetzt
habe ich mir doch je mehr es gruppen
mitgenommen den 23 ich dachte
[Musik]
ich dachte eigentlich dass es dann so
aussieht mit dem meeresboden als werden
dass irgendwelche becher oder so also
hier sollte auf jeden fall so und links
hinter so einem teller sein oder so aber
dann lassen wir halt nur eine da dann
machen wir zwei kommen auch immer zwei
es sieht auf jeden fall so ein bisschen
so aus die sonne kleine bar area es geht
schon wieder fast schon stockfinster
draußen ich schwöre euch wenn da hinten
jetzt im krieg erwartet ganz vorsichtig
ihr hoch gehen hier um ganz vorsichtig
gucken dass hier auch niemand man kommt
höre und sehe auf jeden fall bisher noch
niemanden alles gut alles gut luca und
dann trete ich einfach auf dein bett
sehr gut wir können schlafen meine
lieben freunde und an der stelle würde
ich die heutige episode minecraft mit
luca jetzt auch beenden
wir können kann ich mir durch gucken
gegen diesen baum naja dann nehme auf
jeden fall mal ganz kurz vorne lange ich
zeige euch einmal ganz groß was wir
heute geschafft haben nämlich hier den
weg runter dann hier den weg ein
bisschen ausgebessert dass sie kommt auf
jeden fall in der zeit dann haben wir
hier vorne links auch noch den weg in
platziert da jetzt runter
der jetzt runter geht zu unserer portal
insel da hinten die haben tui neu auf
unsere insel wo ist rooney dahinter ist
er ja da ist die bluetooth 2.0 und das
größte was wir heute geschafft haben was
auch am längsten zeit beansprucht hat
meine lieben freunde und das tut mir
auch leid und den ganzen time lab das
heute dass das mal sein muss allerdings
wirklich hat nicht viel reden allerdings
[Musik]
ja das haben wir heute geschafft meine
lieben freunde ihr seht da hinten schon
die küche ihr seht so ein bisschen den
den barbereich da oben kommt dann auch
noch das zweite stockwerk demnächst
drauf da beschäftigen uns demnächst mal
mit dir an nur noch ein halbes deck
quartz das heißt wir müssen demnächst
auf jeden fall auch noch mal wieder
unten in den neckar reingehen und ein
bisschen quatsch fahren an der stelle
durch die heutige wieso die minecraft
mit douglas allerdings erst mal beenden
wenn es euch trotz meiner behinderung
hier heute so kann man es ja wirklich
nennen gefallen hat das gern einen
daumen hoch unter dem video hier da
abonniert neuen kanal und menschen aber
nennt sich gern auf die glocke so dass
ihr weitere videos nicht verpasst und
schreibt mit bitte mal und in die
kommentare
was ich hier hin bauen soll da wo gerade
der kuhstall ist und dass vielleicht aus
dem baumhaus also nicht aus dem baumhaus
sondern außerdem auch hier hinter dem
baum werden soll
[Musik]